this is the program page and when you
scroll down
you will find the program overview what
actually the program is all about
now
when you scroll down more you will find
the whole framework about the research
fellowship program so as to complete
your
novel research project in a specified
tenure
okay for example introduction
here we'll be telling you about the
overview of our cloud tools of big data
processing then we'll give you uh an
overview about the introductory courses
on bioinformatics and computational
biology
then the second step is we'll be telling
you about how to evaluate uh for example
uh like research topic selection will be
there systematic literature review will
be there
research proposal development which will
include project title project
description reference uh publication and
data sets which will which will you be
working on
then uh we'll be showing the practical
coursework and example projects on
different specialized tracks as
dr raghav just explained for example in
precision oncology in precision medicine
neurosciences agriculture and
bioinformatics etc
then uh
it's about the exploratory analysis
of a focused set of publicly available
data set to identify major trends and
patterns for investigation
then
uh
then the step is
we'll be investigating about the
exploratory data analysis we'll do the
data driven research hypothesis some
statistical testing and inference will
be there
and in the end whatever you have done in
your training and in your
analytical part you will be writing down
and jotting down into a scientific
manuscript or a report writing
then following this we
i'll tell you about the resources and
the tenure
for which you can work on
so there are three different tenures
most probably four different in yours in
this
research fellowship program one is 45
days another is 60 days then it's 90
days and the fourth one is for six
months so there are some common
resources for all these tenure which are
you will have access to our omics logic
learn portal for the training and
learning part you will have access to
our t bioinfo server for the analysis
part then you will have access
to our coding sessions session
recordings then you'll have access to
our online mentor support
online technical support and after the
completion of the program you will be
you will get a certification
so these are the some of the common
resources for all the 10 years now what
the what's the difference between the
three is
in 45 days 10 uh program you will the
analysis will be of a intermediate level
of analysis and it won't be as like an
extensive one
for 60 and 90 days and now
90 days 10 year other than
uh live sessions with the mentor other
than the weekly research fellowship
meetings you have an opportunity to fix
a one-on-one mentor sessions
then for the 90 days tenure with the
certificate of completion you will also
get a certificate of excellence and
again we have the one-on-one mentor uh
mentor opportunity in this particular
tenure also
so there if you scroll above you'll find
a drop down menu
and from here you can particularly
select
in
depending upon your location so right
now i think it's not working for me but
depending upon your location you can
select
in which for example if you are living
in uh us so you will get the amount in
usd if you are living in uh nigeria then
you will get to uh then you will get the
amount in naira if you are living in
india then you will get the amount in
inr so right now it is like the amount
is set for uh us candidates and uh for
45 days the amount is dollar 350. for 60
days it's dollar 450 usd and for 90 days
it's dollar 550 the amount varies per
location
and we do have scholarships for
scholarships you can mail us at
marketing at the right omixlogic.com
and we'll be further discussing and
we'll be further discussing with our
internal team how much scholarship we
can provide and avail you for but we do
provide scholarship up to 50 percent
so uh after this i'll be sharing the
scholarship form
and if you have further queries you can
mail mail us at
marketingxlogic.com or you can contact
us on
uh i'll share the contact information in
the chat box itself
the number is active on whatsapp also so
if you have any doubts regarding the
registration step the fee structure or
the resources please put your question
in the chat box
thank you so much